[Music]
from MVP studios in New York it's Late
Night with Conan O'Brien
[Music]
tonight from Larry King rise Larry King
from the TV show house
Omar ever including the best actor
Sheila Kelley with Max Weinberg in the
Max Weinberg 7 and now here's your host
Conan O'Brien
[Music]
very much alive
yeah I like the vibe tonight I really
like the vibe we got a good show for it
yeah we really do I'm like ready to go
max I am ready to go yeah yeah okay that
was convincing we I am Conan proceed
lots to talk about here to top the show
of course immigration the big topic
right now heard you all talking on the
way in whole crowd was like he's gonna
talk about immigration I hope so here
big story that's how you walk
I saw you you've all been in Oklahoma
yesterday this is big news yesterday the
Senate voted to make English the
national language of the United States
yeah the the vote drew protests from
several immigrant groups and one
governor of California
[Applause]
[Music]
my Arnold always eats a sausage in the
end that's how I do it
even though it is a little bit
controversial President Bush supports
the effort to make English our national
language that's right
president says making English our
national language is not discrimination
this is interesting a little celebrity
dish yesterday in New York City right
here in New York City while Britney
Spears was walking out of a hotel her
baby nearly slipped out of her hands
yeah actually the baby didn't slip out
of her hands it was trying to escape
baby baby looked at mom and dad I'm out
here
george steinbrenner do you hear about
this george steinbrenner has a horse
running in this weekend's Preakness race
Steinbrenner says if the horse doesn't
perform well it will be castrated yeah
yeah then Steinbrenner said the same
thing about Randy Johnson I love that
name Randy Johnson I don't know what I'm
doing uh headed here with this the
National Weather Service issued a
warning today because a funnel cloud was
spotted nearly touching down in New
Jersey yeah luckily the warning reached
the funnel cloud just in time
[Applause]
I really like that one all right go Oh
New Jersey all
oh sorry this week the FBI began looking
for the body of Jimmy Hoffa in a remote
field on the outskirts of Detroit but
they still haven't found anything now
officials officials say it's the first
time they've ever been to Detroit and
not found a body
[Applause]
give my hand come on it's Friday
excellent program though great guests
from Larry King Live and the author of
my dad and me Larry King is here
my Riley Kenny from the TV show house
that's an amazing show Omar Epps
and then you gotta say till the end of
tonight's show creator of the stripper
and pole dancing work out the s factor
I'll be learning how to strip
[Applause]
the next one is an external
yeah terrific show tonight max we got a
lot to do we should we shouldn't waste
any time let's get this show started hey
Conan everybody look it's Will Arnett
from Arrested Development hey
[Music]
well this is a real treat how's it going
there buddy
it's going really good yeah you know
just up here and was in the neighborhood
and I was just watching this show and I
thought maybe if you wanted some help
with some comedy bits I could hop down
there we could do something yeah okay
well well thanks but we're all set
tonight you know we'd sort of got all
our comedy bits all set we're ready to
go so I mean I'm here I've had a couple
pops and I'm ready to go Thanks
we're good though but thank you very
much all right but I'm here crazy
yeah well no will you just sit back and
you know enjoy the show and maybe some
other time you know great I'm a little
drunk so it'll be great to watch well
will arnett everybody Thanks
what's that you know yeah just sit back
will and enjoy the master will edit that
out later all right we have a terrific
terrific show tonight but first there is
something I wanted to mention every so
often don't ask us how we do it we
manage to get big celebrities to sit
down share some of their innermost
secrets with us tonight we have an
international superstar he was willing
to spill his guts for us on camera
reveals some very dark stuff this is
rough take a look my workout routine
it's very simple four times a week I beg
your girlfriend wasn't enough interested
shirts in front of fans all day means
one thing winburn nips most women think
of me as the most romantic man on earth
until they see my poo far ahead
[Applause]
pretty special tonight I I think I think
it's time we take a look into the future
the future Conan told you not to come
down here that's right Will Arnett
[Applause]
[Music]
Mexicans will agree to stop sneaking
into the United States as long as
Americans agree to stop vomiting all
over Cancun God will arrive to judge the
living and the dead as if that weren't
bad enough the whole thing will be
hosted by Jeff Probst magician David
Blaine will be forced to hold his breath
for another six days when his car breaks
down in New Jersey
[Applause]
millions will run for their lives but to
no avail
the bloodshed will be awful and Swift
but when it's over no one will ever call
randy quaid dennis again Barry Bonds
will not be inducted into the Baseball
Hall of Fame but he will be injected
into it punk rockers will stop wearing
mohawk haircuts when they discover that
the original Mohawk Indians were into
smooth jazz
[Applause]
Larry the Cable Guy will admit that he
changed his name from the more Jewish
sounding Larry cableman the 80s pop band
mr. mr. will receive an honorary degree
from the University of Arizona and
thereafter insist on being called dr.
mister the television networks ABC CBS
and Fox will cease to exist and NBC will
still come in fourth
[Applause]
[Music]
in a brilliant case of cutting out the
middleman White Castle will begin
grinding up their burgers and spraying
them all over the inside of toilets
[Applause]
and you're 2,000
you're an ass
[Applause]
how are you feel great very nice so nice
to my wife oh right of course I'm we had
on the show really good singer stinger
with Mack yeah yeah how are you you look
fantastic
feel great keep in shape you know for my
age yeah yeah yeah getting old no no 51
52 uh
about 72 are you 72 years old yeah good
yeah you look fantastic I can't believe
I married someone much younger than me
that's well you have two young children
how how young are these kids chances
seven and Kenan will be six on Monday
six and seven yeah do people how do
people react when you're walking down
the street with a six year old and a
seven year old I was in the last time I
was in New York with the whole family I
was walking down sixth Avenue and we
passed a homeless person and he looked
up as a black king beautiful daughter
nice grandchildren $20 bill and put it
right back in your pocket but what I do
do is when people see me and my wife
together mm-hmm and there's an obvious
age difference yeah I always tell them
the same thing right she dies she dies
[Laughter]
now let me ask you something you
mentioned their names their names are
chance chances how'd you come up with
the name chance we met by chance I mean
when everybody meets by chance yeah we
named him chance it's a nice name he's
very proud of his name he's a Dodger he
wants to be a Dodger he said the Dodger
game tonight right
very good and what about the second
child's name is Kenan Kenan how did you
come up that name he was conceived on
Canon Drive and but you were driving
when you
well your fenders get stuck in the stick
shift I have to choke and I have a two
and a half year old daughter and I have
a six month old son yeah there's chance
and canon your young kids what makes are
you able to make your kids laugh and
what makes them laugh what is their
stuff you can do that chance they don't
make laugh too much chance is very
serious very analytical and
seven-year-old he wonders about
everything he would say if I said
something funny what do you mean by that
mm-hmm but canon is it comedic canon I
swear to you will be the next Conan kids
got a dream--big shouldn't set on Conan
right away you know Kenan King is he's
funny he wakes up in the morning funny
yeah we do things like I invent the
language and he responds but what kind
of stuff do you say to him I say to him
guac Ibaka's ego and he'll say sugar
pocket Agha right not beginning to
understand him
yeah care if you get in trouble if you
were on the phone someone's on the phone
talking to I mean you're like zebra
dhaba Guba they'd be like Larry's losing
it
sometimes he responds great you know in
a comedic fashion like I'll say ball I'm
a gay guy and he goes follow along here
you go you know he's like these really
reacted right right shocked at the move
right now it's simply something like
watching kids girl might be frightened
dad that's not a word
do you does he is he already zeroing in
on you know professionals who he thinks
her funny because you you're around
comedians all the time they come a long
time all the time but the fine Canon is
a comedian with everyone but chance
mm-hmm my wife Sean opened for Rickles
Don Rickles the great diner osburgh the
great Don Rickles in he loves you and
you were to have him on a lot more
because this is fine he's 80 years old
now he's been on the show several times
hilarious yes sir
chance seven years old sits in the
audience at the Stardust Hotel and goes
funny that's funny
Rickles cause of Rickles yeah that goes
is run me that's wait a min the front
seat of a nightclub at night watching
funny Don funny yeah some drinks over
here baby shake that thing
you're like if you're gonna be in show
but they're too great yeah yeah yeah I
don't they go to public school exactly
to do that you know I don't do the
private route and I just I you know
life's good cheer sounds very good and
and we mentioned your your beautiful
wife we actually have a photo of here
she was on the show Sean King but we
haven't there she is gorgeous women love
Larry King they just do
is this true what's the secret what's
the secret Larry I have no freaking idea
thanks for changing that word at the
last second did you see which way that
was going in Larry's like 45 years
broadcasting freaking no I I have people
here like girls just say the word where
you're cute or you know and I have never
figured out for example I am to me I am
totally nondescript I am if I weren't
like cut if people didn't recognize me
because the television I think I look
like a meter reader you mean you think
you be a guy that just blends into the
background my nose is a little big
mm-hmm my chin is ordinary my eyes you
get a close-up of the eyes I have
nothing brown eyes
they're just nondescript brown eyes a
little bit of eyebrows I have keep
looking keep looking
stay on that shot
you don't keep looking I love the idea
of anyone turning on the show right now
let's check out my peepers right here
get in tight yeah I got nothing going on
in here between me and Larry Larry you
look to your camera I look to my camera
moving I just cut back and forth dueling
on but someone played a little weird
camera Larry let's go here we go
[Applause]
anyone turning on the show at that
moment doesn't know what's happening
which is usually happens a lot with this
yeah it was it was a compliment I was
you know one of the best things I've
ever done
proudest things was in the year 2000 I
guess where you came on I did the year
2000 love that yeah yeah you did a great
job of course Conan it is 2006 we're too
we're too cheap to change the graphic
we've updated would it cost $80 to
change the graphic like we're not
changing that thing I've been doing that
I've been I started that doing that bit
I did it first in Chicago in 1988 and
that's when the year 2000 seemed like
the distant future now we're just gonna
leave when are you coming up go away
come out to LA I don't know it's gonna
be a while it's good I'm here I'm here
for now I'm here for you anytime you
want to drop by and we can stare into
each other's eyes on television :
yeah I never thought
[Music]
[Applause]
that was good two careers you know what
I always have so much fun when you come
on the show you're a good man Larry King
Live airs daily at 9:00 on CNN and my
dad and me is in stores now
Larry King thank you so much my next
guest tonight is is that doorbell come
in evening sir I was just passing by and
say that's a lovely desk you have there
I haven't seen wood that nice since they
passed out in kim novak toolshed that
curvy ice queen show gave me vertigo
who are you are you a traveling salesman
oh no that's absurd Hannigan's the name
and I swear on the lives of my fictional
children that I'm not selling anything I
just need to borrow a fire extinguisher
a fire extinguisher why to put out my
briefcase it's full of red hot deals I
knew it you are a Salesman actually
sales implies that I've ever actually
sold something and man implies that it
didn't lose my penis in a death
prostitutes hastily closed car oh my god
that's disgusting nauseated eh
then you need some of these dot queasy
tummy tablets taking people's minds off
nausea with crippling leg pain since
1882 now with more polio I'm not buying
a jar full of polio say you're pretty
tense why don't you loosen up with this
doc end it alls relaxation pistol
blasting away anxiety with 38 caliber
tranquility pellets since 1927 okay I
know I am NOT blowing my brains out get
out of here I have a comedy show to do
comedy eh
I heard more laughs during the Bay of
Pigs invasion gut-busting jokes from the
good people of joke oh okay well I could
always use some jokes that you got any
Tom Cruise Katie Holmes jokes or do I
put on your wolf suit I'm about to make
you howl say that Tom Cruise and Katie
Holmes sure look happy if they were any
bigger lovebirds say their beaks and lay
eggs in a birdhouse what do you think
that was terrible it was awful to subtly
how about a line drive laughs data for
my more accessible Jericho line okay
fine you got a joke about the new
Fantastic Four movie do I hop on the
giggle ship or off the Chuckle Island
boy that Fantastic Four movie sure is
highly anticipated it fit anymore buzz
it'd be a bus or a bee or Hornet or
something else it buzzes maybe an old TV
and that astronaut Buzz Aldrin was Buzz
his real name or just a nickname who
cares that whole moon landing was faked
anyway transcript
I think that was the worst joke I've
ever heard in my life
then you haven't heard this one about
the combined weight of Bell Biv DeVoe
tell pip to vote no one's mentioned that
me in 15 years
why don't you sell things people
actually want like what I don't know a
nice watch or a car or something how
about a BMW wait a minute you can get me
a BMW yep a bisexual Mexican well there
get in here too
[Applause]
I'm sorry I'm sorry but I want that guy
out of here give him a try trust me he
doesn't need that blowtorch to fire you
up okay so get it just get out okay
drive a hard bargain I'll give me a doc
queasy tummy tablets the relaxation
pisto the Tom Cruise Katie Holmes dope
the life changing fantastic for knee
slapper with the buzz aldrin tag and a
career-ending public three-way with me
and chee chee here for $12 even you know
first of all congratulations this show
house it's a great show and it's a huge
hit this is a good thing for you I'm
just enjoying the ride
yeah do you I mean sometimes I talk to
people that are on hit shows and they
tell me that they watch their own show
when it comes on I know a lot of people
that get together and have parties to
watch a show like house do you watch it
every week yeah when I get the chance
and yeah thank God for TiVo do you joy
are you able to get into it as a story
or you just want you know and watching
yourself no I'm cool and watching myself
I just can't do the blood thing I'm just
there's a lot of medical sort of
squeamish really start cutting right I
can't watch that's what does it bother
you while you're doing it on the set or
does it just bother you to watch it
later on it's cool it's normal when I'm
doing it on and said it's like you know
I'm an actor this is what we do right at
home my wife is like yeah whoops yeah
what's wrong with you and I got like
really turn away right you can't handle
it it's that's weird and when you're
doing of course I guess when you're
doing it you can see that it's fake but
maybe when you're watching it on
television they're so good at making it
look Leo I just you know needles blood
just doesn't work well for me right we
okay you mentioned you mentioned your
wife I want to ask you this you you got
when you know for years you got a lot of
sexy love scenes you know as an actor
and then you got married and they're
they don't seem to be happening anymore
yeah is that your is that your wife
intervening in this whole situation you
mean big sister
yeah she's got the fix in on me man I
can't get a chick anymore on screen yeah
yeah
I can do good save me neither
on screen so what do you think's
happening you think she's talking to
your agent and saying kill that part
where you're the got something going on
I don't know
yeah she's got the fix in on me spell on
you yeah yes I mean it's like I got a
stench on me know what I wasn't gonna
say anything you know I forgot about
this but you were a professional dancer
for a while fashionable dancer yeah like
you were well you were dead state you
dance yes yes I know I was one of those
but not but you tore it with Queen
Latifah yeah your backup dancers way to
say I used to thank you thank you backup
dancer for Queen Latifah when I was 17
Wow yeah went on the road with her and
uh she's a great woman well you have to
be an amazing shape to do that and have
good moves do you still I mean you're
still a young guy do you like to dance
still dancing to me is like sitting on
the wall bobbing my head with the drink
that's what how I dance now really yeah
the knees just don't hold up anymore you
know I used to be able to jump off of
stuff and land and split and all that
and right just not happening it's not
happening anymore not going down because
I still get in there and I starts
flailing I just you're good with the
thing in the
[Applause]
those moves work for me I won't
recommend them for anybody else I
actually do that at home you do that now
it's touching on its stamping the nation
it's like the and the wife loves it yeah
the ladies maybe do the coding dance
[Applause]
[Music]
we know we have Sheila Kelley coming on
the show and in the next segment and she
is going to be teaching me some
striptease moves and that is a huge fad
in Los Angeles right now
Maurice Angeles yes nowhere else of
course I'm curious to learn more about
this stripping they call it but it's
it's really become a fad out there and
and and now I'm hearing that like people
are a lot of people are going to strip
clubs is kind of a cool thing to do is
that something that you that you ever do
I've been sure to explore that thing
they call stripping stripping yeah yeah
yeah take the wife man that's you Cho
you take your wife safe his way to do it
how do you go to a strip how do you go
to a strip club with your wife she's a
renaissance woman yeah she enjoys yeah
all aspects of it I know I think she's
just looking at me yeah that's what I
was in a strip club with my wife no
matter who came out and what they were
doing it have to be gone like Oh God
exactly
[Laughter]
naked women repulsive now I'm gonna get
you in a lot of trouble when you go home
I got I really am congratulations on the
season finale of house which is going to
be huge airs Tuesday night at 9:00 on
Fox they will congratulations have a lot
of questions and then I guess I'm gonna
learn yes there's nothing I can't do so
accept pole dance why is it called the s
factor the s factor after the shape of a
woman's body
the curves of a the S kind of mimic the
shape of a woman's body as opposed to
like a man who's more like of an H we're
an thanks a lot you guys are more linear
and squared most workouts are linear and
very square and right this is a very
different way of moving your body into
your curves right in kendo can a man I
mean I'll be trying to do this but can a
man learn to become an ass if he's an H
I love the idea of trying to teach you
how to do this I've taught a few men a
few men and so we'll see we'll see how
it goes now you started doing pole
dancing this is a quite a while ago and
you installed a pole in your house when
you first got started you went out and
you got a stripper pole and installed it
in the house how did your husband react
to that well the only room I could I
could fit it in was his office mm-hmm
and I had to put it I know I had to put
it between his Stairmaster and the TV
right and he was very unhappy about it
was like no get the pole out no no no
that's so weird you're you're stripping
is blocking the TV
they're lasted for about about 17
minutes right Manning you know I started
working out and then he was like he was
fine if he was moved out and then you
you moved
stripper poles to different parts of the
house how many are there in the house
right I have four four I do four
stripper poles throughout the house I do
okay this is how I got three in my
bedroom or my bedroom
two in your bedroom so you can fly from
one to the other that's exciting
and one on my patio patio yeah
what are the neighbors who are
barbecuing doing when you're on the
stripper pole I don't know I haven't
seen them yet I haven't met them yet we
just moved into this one okay so you're
gonna get people looking over the hedges
I think and you wear do you wear that
you wear some sexy stuff while you're
yeah okay yeah it's it we have eats like
a little stripper shorts oh yes I do
oh yeah you need to have your legs fair
when you're climbing and doing work up
on the pole right right really it's the
most amazing workout you have ever done
yeah well I have ever done
all right you could just work every
muscle in your body okay I have like two
muscles in my body then one of them just
doesn't work at all that was bad
[Applause]
let's let's find out what's going on you
tell me what I need to do we got a
stripper pole here and what do I need to
chew I okay I'm getting my ass going any
pole work you want to be warm warm okay
what do we do your back up against the
pole my back right here your upper back
and then walk your feet out on your toes
like right here yeah go go up on your
toes okay get your hips away out like me
[Applause]
I can't feel anything
right right okay go push it push it push
it
take an inhale take your butt all the
way back against the pole nice okay I
can't okay that that broke a few thing
that was a stretch that was just a
stretch right there
getting warmed up here I'm loose now
okay we're teaching your first trick
liquid snake what's that okay okay slow
it down all right so I want you to the
first trick okay you go call it a
Firefly your right hands above your head
left hands over here you're gonna swing
your left hand foot and fly
it's not gonna look like that it's not
gonna look anything like that all right
okay okay all right what am i doing
either you swing your left hand onto
your right hand under my right hand
swing your left foot hook it and throw
your body of me and for my boy put my
whole body that's a lot of man coming
your way
go
[Applause]
we had a small heart attack during it
halfway through its just stopped I love
your techie make it straight I want you
to work on your landings make them more
fluid okay all right what's that
take your poison that the body spiral
right okay
body Farrell you're gonna come out swing
out oh my god fly back okay that's not
gonna happen
you do you look incredibly sexy when
you're doing these things so what tell
me what to do I'm where you're going to
step over here uh-huh and then you're
going to grab the pole up here Oh pull
the pool under your arm I'm gonna pull
the pole under my arm
yeah no now okay what am I gonna do well
your buddy bad luck from my body that
way yeah okay here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
doesn't require spinning okay okay what
do you want to do call the snake okay
left hand over though I know the snake
okay lift your left leg up yeah curl
remember the ending is the landing is
the most important part right yes yes of
course oh my god you're gonna let
yourself just slowly come down the hole
you're gonna like be a wet piece of
spaghetti you're just gonna be a wet
piece of spaghetti I don't think I can
get upside down I don't know I really
don't okay you're gonna have to help me
with this one what do i do yeah it's
never my human leg has never been up
above this position right now
[Applause]
I know I think we're out of time and I
have to get the blood back down here
that was incredible like that I really
did you know it was another reason you
left you have to come back sometimes
that was a lot of fun Sheila tell
everybody I look like I've been drinking
alright I do want to thank my guests as
Sheila Kelly that was a lot of fun
Kelley's s factor has seven locations
for DVDs are available online and you
just opened a studio in New York in New
York and in the Hamptons all right well
check it out everybody and big thanks to
Larry King a big thanks to our one of my
favorite plenty people will arnett we're
stopping by
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here we go
[Music]
it doesn't require spinning okay okay
what do you want me to do baba snake
okay left hand over though I know the
snake you lift your left leg up yeah
curl remember the ending is the landing
is the most important part right yes yes
of course
oh my god you're gonna let yourself just
slowly come down the pole you're gonna
make me a wet piece of spaghetti you're
just gonna be a wet piece of spaghetti
[Applause]